[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour la première fois au québec un
théâtre institutionnel présente une
pièce mettant en vedette presque
exclusivement des comédiens noirs
pensait pas voir ça de mon vivant je
pense je pensais surtout pas en fait
conques ont montré un classique à foix
merkel une pièce noire héritage est un
classique du théâtre américain est la
première pièce d'une autre histoire
jouée sur broadway
les personnages dans cette caisse
nations comme les dix ans riches sont
complexes
son tombeau dans leur sélection puis
texte excessivement touche en fait la
pièce raconte l'histoire d'une famille
qui se déchire autour d'un héritage
en fait la pièce est vraiment comme un
genre de belz l'on compare ici à notre
belles soeurs de michel tremblay donc
c'est vraiment de s'identifier à une
famille qu'ils s'aiment qui vit toute
sorte de wii 2 bat donc n'importe qui
peut juste des personnes noires racisées
peu syndic peut s'identifier aux
personnages signe qu'un an après la
controverse qui a entouré les spectacles
slave kamata les choses changent
moi je tu arrives à une époque où est ce
que la question sur la représentativité
et n'était pas encore le les acteurs
ethniques ont enfin les acteurs refusent
ils vont pouvoir vraiment prendre leur
place puis puis s'émanciper complètement
en tant qu' en tant qu'artiste la troupe
espère attirer un nouveau public au
théâtre et même susciter des vocations
j'ai décidé de faire ce métier là dans
la salle chez duceppe quand j'avais 13
ans un peu premier parrain t'abonner
nous avait amené moi c'est en voyant du
théâtre que j'ai même si j'étais pas
représenter en termes de couleurs
l'important c'était j'ai eu cette envie
là si héritage pouvait donner soif jeune
génération dite de la diversité de
s'intéresser au théâtre et aux arts de
la scène ça ça serait si ont accompli
ici l'ebit alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal